so you found a new job
congratulations
now comes the official
sign part of the employment contract
but what should you pay attention to
when signing an employment contract
start with some basics
is it a contract
for a definite or indefinite period
and it contains a fixed number of hours
or is it a flexible contract
if you have certainty about that
then you can move on to more difficult things
for example a probationary period
it is nice to have certainty about your probationary period
because a probationary period
to begin with,
must comply with a number of rules
but you also need to know as an employee
that you can just be sent away by your employer
that you can always leave during your probationary period
always look closely
whether a non-competition clause is in your agreement
a study costs clause
and whether there is a collective labor agreement
applies to your employment contract
and if so which collective labor agreement
always check what the rules are
in case of illness
you will continue to be paid seventy percent of your wages
in case of illness or perhaps one hundred percent
make sure you know that
finally look at your notice period
this is the deadline to pass
after which you can actually leave your employer